hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
the passage of time it gets to us all
doesn't it i've been doing this podcast
for over three years now i remember
almost every one
that i've done actually i remember
everyone but i don't remember any of the
ones that i haven't
yet done there's an asymmetry right in
my memory
between the podcasts that i've already
done in the past and the podcast yet to
come in the future
not because there aren't any in the
future but because of some feature of
the way that time
works in our universe the arrow of time
pointing from the past to the future
that gives it
that imbalance and this is one of my
favorite topics to think about in
physics and philosophy and the amazing
thing is
we haven't really talked about it here
on the podcast yet we did talk about
time uh the psychology and neuroscience
of time with dean bonamano
but the physics and philosophy of the
arrow of time which was the subject of
my first
trade book from eternity to here we
haven't talked about yet
also surprising is that we have not yet
had david wallace on the podcast
david is one of the leading philosophers
of physics in the world today
the third surprising thing is that we're
having david on and we're not talking
that much about the many world's
interpretation of quantum mechanics
david is most famous
for being probably the person who has
thought most carefully about how many
worlds should work in the real world
i all encourage you to check out his
book the emergent multiverse if you
really want to dig
into the details but david is broad in
his interests in physics and philosophy
and he's
certainly thought a lot about entropy
and the arrow of time and the initial
conditions of the universe and so forth
that's what we're going to be mostly
talking about today
how are all these different things
related in you know the typical
good philosopher very very careful way
of teasing out what all the assumptions
are
how they go into things i know that i've
found by talking to people that the
arrow of time is one of the
hardest things to think about in a
reasonable way just because
this idea that the past flows into the
future
is so deeply embedded in how we think
about the world
that the idea that it's something that
has to be explained
and that you're not allowed to cheat
when you explain it
is a hard one to wrap your mind around
but david is very very good at it and
guess what by the end of the podcast we
are in fact talking about the everett
many worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics because it has a
relationship to the arrow of time the
universe branches
into multiple copies of itself going
forward in time
not going backwards so i think this is a
classic upcoming episode here of the
mindscape podcast and you're all going
to enjoy it so let's go
david wallace welcome to the mindscape
podcast great to be here
you know we're uh we've had some
philosophers on the podcast before
in fact philosophers of science in fact
philosophers who started out as
physicists and then turned into science
like our friend david albert for example
but
but nevertheless i thought it'd be fun
to start by just asking you
um about that transition you know very
quickly before we get into the
mean potatoes of the thing what is it
that causes a person
to sort of at one time in their lives
think i want to be a physicist and at
some other time
think you know i'd really be happier
doing philosophy
well i think there's a bunch of people
who get into physics and then gradually
start thinking that
a more philosophical way of exploring
things is more interesting and they want
to move in that direction
i'm not that kind of person at all i
still want to do physics
largely i still think i do do physics uh
the kind of work i do is
interdisciplinary and
i think relatively mundane facts about
the way britain and america organize
their universities mean that for the
kind of physics
or interdisciplinary stuff i was
interested in
staying in a physics department and
trying to do that work wouldn't have
been the smartest career move
right so i kind of finished my phd in
physics
with a bunch of research interests that
were kind of in various foundational
things quantum field theory
the everest interpretation and it looked
pretty clear
that i'd probably be able to get
postdocs that way relatively easily
because everyone says they love interest
and when i started looking for
tenure-track physicians i'd be short of
luck
right so it was it was a fairly
practical career move i don't understate
how
how cool academic philosophy is or say
that i haven't developed lots of
interests beyond that
through exposure to it because i really
have but it really did come down to that
kind of i want to do
i want to do this kind of physics where
can i do it how can i do it i mean it is
a
indictment i think of the academic
system at least in the uk
and the usa which is the ones we're
familiar with that
the siloing is is strong enough that
there's there isn't a spectrum in
between these right i mean
uh you are either a philosopher or a
physicist
because you need to get paid you need to
get a job and and that that affects how
people choose their research topics and
things like that
yeah yeah and and um people like it to
this
new work in principle but when it starts
to be you want a permanent position you
have a teaching component
it gets hard and i do think it's a
genuinely hard problem to solve
i mean one of the reasons foundational
philosophical works tricky to do in a
physics department
is the criteria to measure it hard right
so you've done an experiment the
experiment does what you said it did
you've done a calculation the
calculation can be checked all that's
fine
um harder to do that with foundational
stuff i mean and yeah as we both know
some genuinely bad stuff gets done in
foundational spaces
which doesn't get caught by those kind
of filters so i think it is an
indictment but i also do think it's a
tricky problem to solve
and maybe one reason philosophy of
physics works quite well as a space is
philosophy is a bit better and knowing
how to assess for quality
that kind of more conceptual oriented
work that makes perfect sense and
actually it leads very well
into the meat and potatoes here because
my own
and i think i've said this before but
maybe not to you you know i was always
interested in philosophy ever since i
was an undergraduate but
the kinds of philosophy that i liked
were actually moral and political
philosophy
because the philosophy of science that i
learned was all about
theory choice and sociology of science
and stuff like that which is important
and interesting but it's not my bag
it wasn't until i was a grown
cosmologist and thinking about the early
universe
uh that i came across uh a bunch of
philosophers who were really like you
say
really doing physics right uh people
like hugh price and david albert and tim
walden and yourself
um who are trying to understand how the
universe works and it was through so
through the arrow of time that i
actually got interested
in uh philosophical foundational
questions and so
i thought it'd be fun to start talking
about that before we get into the
everett interpretation so the phrase the
arrow of time
something people have heard but then
there's this feeling that there are many
arrows of time i mean what is your take
on is there an
arrow of time are there many what are
they how do you define them
the basic way i started getting at it is
something about
which processes in the world run
forwards and backwards
just as happily and which processes
don't so if you look at
if you look at small systems or not
really even just the small systems but
if you look at
systems with not many moving parts in
physics they don't seem to care whether
you run them forward or backwards so if
i showed you a video of the solar system
and i speeded it up a bit
and i asked you whether i was running it
forward or backward i mean if you paid
attention to whether the sun rose in the
east or the west or something you could
probably figure it out
but it wouldn't be obvious um the solar
system's physics doesn't really mind if
you run it forward or backward
and that's just the same reason why the
the way we work out when
when the next eclipse is going to be is
just the same way we work out when the
eclipses were in
in the classical area so we can cross
reference it to the usability or
something
those processes aren't like that
processes with lots of moving parts i
don't like that
if i show you a speed of that video of
uh
ice cube in water or um
all the way i've got i've got older over
the last 10 years or
uh you know building collapsing or
something it's completely obvious
whether i'm running
that video forward or backward so most
processes in the world
um really distinguish between
forward and backward dynamics um and yet
big things are made out of small things
so there's something extremely puzzling
kind of in the vicinity of a
contradiction if you're not careful with
the idea that big processes
clearly distinguish forward and backward
in the dynamics but they're made out of
processes that
themselves don't distinguish it do you
do you yourself
like to you know rigorously categorize
different arrows of time or do you just
lump it together as an arrow of time and
different aspects of it yeah i'm kind of
skeptical
about a lot of that categorizing of
different arrows i think you know people
do talk about a
um a statistical thermodynamic arrow and
a cosmological arrow
and a memory arrow and i think
the the way you break those things up uh
kind of presuppose a structure that's
not necessarily there
i don't think we should necessarily take
it as read
but the direction of time implied by the
fact that we remember the past not the
future
is has the same origin as the as would
be assumed
uh as the direction we get from for the
fact that ice melts and doesn't refreeze
but if we just kind of silo them off
then we
can kind of assume that we know what how
those things break up in a way that
isn't completely reliable
and i think one way of seeing that
actually is you start
if you want to check if two things are
logically independent you want to try
switching one of them off and leaving
the other one on and seeing if it makes
sense if you try to imagine universes
where you turn around let's say the
direction in which you remember things
or the direction in which radiation
decays but you don't turn around the
direction in which
um ice melts you very quickly have
something you can't
really imagine when you start trying to
think through the details in any length
so in other words just to sort of leap
ahead to a big claim that we'll
interrogate later
you seem to be saying that in your view
there is one
underlying thing that uh ultimately is
going to account for both why
ice melts but doesn't unmelt and also
for why we remember the past but not the
future
well look i reckon that's true but i'll
do a slightly more sort of
drawn back version for that i'm pretty
sure
that the reason that if there's a
relation between those two
then the direction of time in human
cognition and action
is what it is because of the direction
of time in physics
and not vice versa so we ought to be
able to figure out what's going on in
the direction in the direction of time
in physics without having to presuppose
a bunch of stuff
from human cognition and action
uh if once we've done that then i kind
of strongly suspect that because humans
are physical systems
it's going to turn out that asymmetries
in humans are a special case of these
other asymmetries
but at the very least we could figure
out those asymmetries in physics without
having to get tangled up in these
issues about asymmetries in us
but this so this does pre presuppose
and you're in a friendly crowd here so
it's okay a kind of
uh physicalism right i mean uh we're not
attributing
human agency to something over and above
the fact that we're made of stuff so
if we understand the asymmetries of the
behavior of the stuff
the asymmetries of human thought and
cognition should follow along
right yeah absolutely there's a
substantial assumption going on here and
there's a sense in which i'm not even
seriously defending it it's it's a bit
too foundational to start defending
um you might kind of draw it up like
this there's this kind of
approach i think you're calling
physicalism uh some places i've just
called it like dynamics first that says
something like
okay the the way we manage our science
is it's a dynamical description of
what's going on
independent of us it's as far as we
interact with it that matters because
it's how we test stuff and because we
want to understand us too
but the physics itself can be understood
without and without
consideration of the agent's role and
there's a completely different tradition
that says well the theories can't be
understood
except insofar as they are things to be
used by theorizers
and the role of the theorizer can never
be taken out completely so
you'll never you'll never really
understand the asymmetry of time in in
physics without understanding there's an
asymmetry
in how we as agents get our systems look
some
some smart reasonable people take that
approach and it
and sometimes it bears fruit and and
there comes a time
where i think it's less useful to just
go round and round never decreasing
circles
try to persuade somebody who has that
starting point they're wrong and it
makes more sense to pursue your own
project
and have it judged by its fruits that's
right if you succeed then the
good things will flow in your direction
right okay so i mean
you mentioned i think very correctly
that naively
this asymmetry of time evolution of big
complicated things
might be thought of as intention or even
contradictory to the symmetry of time
evolution
in things with small number of moving
pieces before we explain why
do you know much about the history like
who's the first person who pointed out
this was a puzzle so i should know this
lots of philosophers of physics are
really good at the history of physics
i'm not one of those foster physics but
i hang out with them a lot so i can do
my
attempted secondhand version i mean
back in the late 19th century when
boltzmann was first trying to write down
mechanical theories
of um of gases these ideas were in the
air and developing and there was clearly
a lot of confusion and it's one of these
quite delicate things to tease out
exactly who knew what
when but roughly speaking boltzmann had
a stab
at doing an entirely mechanical
explanation of why gases expand and
expand to fill the space they're in and
why they
approach a an equilibrium a kind of
stable
well-behaved distribution of a certain
kind and he kind of
at least on the natural reading of it he
wrote a paper that kind of tried to just
prove this mechanically
and then a bunch of people's zamayla
lost schmidt pointed out like this is
logically impossible
you started with some time reversible
equations you made some time reversible
assumptions about those equations and
you got out something which
distinguishes the past of the future
this can't be done
and also you start with this is a
slightly subtler point but you started
with some equations which reliably say
that wherever system starts off it will
eventually get back there
and you've derived the fact that the
system will start somewhere go somewhere
else and stay there forever
this cannot happen so i think really
very early on
you know before statistical mechanics
was a properly developed discipline
right right at the very first attempts
to do this stuff
then people were very quickly seeing
that there was an issue there
i don't think it was much before
boltzmann because you had to have a
a realistic and detailed understanding
of how
the lodge came out of the small to get
the worry off the ground i mean i think
newton kind of liked the idea that
there might be like an atomistic basis
for everything but it was so embryonic
at that point that i didn't think
anyone's serious that i'm aware of
seriously tried to think through what
the what possible issues that
were there well i i guess one of the
reasons i'm asking is just because
i don't know the answer and i've kind of
wondered about this i mean um
i don't want to you know say too many
things rather than asking you to say
them but
there is the second law of
thermodynamics which roughly says that
entropy increases and we can get into
that but
it predates boltzmann like boltzmann
gave an explanation for it in terms of
atoms and molecules bumping into each
other
so i've always wondered you know once
they did come up you know carno and
clausius and people like that they they
invented the second law
manifestly not time reversible
right i mean it it increases with time
it doesn't decrease
and they also knew that there were
newton's laws of motion like that was
well known
and so did anyone did was the idea that
things like the second law were
over and above newton's laws of motion
or was there even a
hope of deriving them from the start and
maybe the answer is you don't know
because i certainly don't know and i've
definitely tried to find out
i mean the sense i have is that the
apparent problem there just doesn't bite
unless you've got a kind of
broadly in the good sense reductionist
picture of what's going on in the world
i mean
if you think that newton's laws are
supposed to be laws for everything
then you can see the contradiction's
going to turn out pretty fast
if you think newton's laws is a great
for you know planets
and um cannonballs
and they're not great for living things
or for
clouts then uh then you're not going to
be so bothered there'll be bits you'll
have a fundamentally
pluralist world you're only beginning to
understand and you don't know how all
bits connect together and the fact that
the
the bit that describes small mechanical
stuff has a
symmetry and time and the bit describes
steam engines doesn't have a symmetry
time isn't going to bother you
and we can look back now and think how
inevitable it ought to be that these
things get put together but you've got
to remember if
even in the early 20th century people
were still
taking extremely seriously the idea that
living tissue was not described by the
same
laws of physics that described
non-living matter that there were
ground-level laws of nature that applied
to living tissues that identified
non-living tissue and it wasn't even a
stupid thing to think i mean it was
always a little unimaginative but they
didn't know about quantum mechanics um
so see i think i think the discovery
that the world actually is
really pretty unified and that in the
good sense it's pretty reductionist
is a a really substantive important
discovery of 20th century science
we don't want to just read it back as
some automatic approach fact about the
night about
science that they could have known just
by cognition in the 19th century so
that's my sense of it
it's only it's only when boltzmann
actually writes down something that
starts looking like a proper mechanical
description
of steam or gases or at a bit more
early than that when maxwell's starting
to do similar things it's only once
people are starting to actually
put in the connective tissue between
mechanics and
um thermodynamics and starting to get
results that make it plausible that
they're connected in this way
that you start seeing the bite of the
tension
between that's that's my sense of it but
again it's historically not super
informed
no but actually it makes a lot of sense
and it uh i like it because
if anything it elevates
the accomplishment of maxwell and
boltzmann and their friends i mean it's
not just that they
uh helped establish statistical
mechanics but
reductionism or you know even the unity
of science in some sense right the idea
that human beings are made of the same
stuff and obey the same laws that atoms
do is
is as exactly as you say whoever came up
with it it's a non-trivial step
yep all of us are trying to get in shape
and eat right
freshly is here to help freshly's
delicious meals are designed
by nutritionists and cooked by chefs
making it easier for you
to eat better freshly is not a meal kit
that gives you ingredients that you have
to cook
freshly offers chef made nutrition
packed delicious meals delivered
fresh to your door your meals arrive
cooked and fresh every week so you can
keep your fridge stocked
and skip the trip to the store one of
the things that i like most about it is
that there's no waste you don't buy
food and then not use it because
everything that you get in the package
is something that you will eat
during that meal your meals are always
delivered fresh never frozen
and are ready to heat and enjoy in just
three minutes
with new meals added each week freshly
brings the convenience of chef made
nutritionist designed classics right to
your kitchen
and right now freshly is offering our
listeners forty dollars off your first
two orders when you go to freshly.com
mindscape so stop stressing about dinner
go to fresh
dot com slash mindscape for forty
dollars off your first two orders that's
freshly.com
mindscape and so then this leads us into
what boltzmann did so
how what was the uh
the insight into entropy and
disorderliness and and time that that
boltzmann and his friends came up with
well again abstracting a little bit from
how how that kind of very messy history
turned out
history is not our primary goal here
what they started what they
started to realize was something like
okay it's not
it can't be that you could just
logically derive
the the asymmetries the expansion of
gases the second law
in your example from from these
mechanics you have to put some
additional assumption in
and the additional assumptions they put
in or at least one of them one of the
ones that
gets a lot of attraction was some notion
of probability
um it was some idea that okay the
the gas can't um the gap you can't be
sure that the gas will
expand to fill the box but it's
extremely likely it's going to
and to some extent that notion of
extremely likely gets cashed out
combinatorically like how many ways
could the gas be
and like almost all the ways the gas
could be in this cashing out a ways
which is going to expand
that's kind of a bit dodgy because
there's like infinitely many ways the
gas could be
and so comparing the numbers is
questionable but but that kind of basic
idea
was there that what what was going to
solve the problem was going to be
probability
and the funny thing is that um that
that lesson actually i think that idea
that you you you get around this paradox
by introducing probability
is still i think quite often what you
run into in the kind of second year
undergraduate statistical mechanics
course
that wants to spend the first lecture
during the history of the subject so it
could be lectures 2 through 16 to
teach you how to calculate partition
functions
um but you step back for just a moment
and of course it can't be true by itself
because leaving aside entirely some
really deep questions about how we
understand probability in this context
the mere introduction of probability
doesn't break the time reversibility
if it's if you want to say over it's
overwhelmingly probable
that the gas is going to evolve to fill
the box in the future
but you don't want to say it's
overwhelmingly probable
that the gas is going to it's going to
have been such that in the past
it filled the box then somewhere you
must have broken the time in symmetry
and so the time symmetry and appealing
to probability by itself
doesn't change that paradox at all and i
think actually i just want to dwell on
that statement because it was
beautifully put
and it's at the heart of a lot of
difficulty i think that people have
with the arrow of time and with related
notions because
they come up with some statements some
purported explanations that all sound
good
but even though what they're trying to
explain is the asymmetry of time they
don't go through the exercise of running
that thing backward in time and seeing
if it sounds just as good
absolutely yeah i i have a article i did
this a while ago said
could you decide to say garbage in
garbage out um if your
input is is a mess you're gonna get out
your outfits are best however clever
your program is
so the slogan in statistical mechanics
or philosophy of statistical mechanics
ought to be
uh reversibility in reversibility out if
the assumptions you make
don't break the symmetry of the problem
they don't distinguish past the future
in some sense it doesn't matter how
clever your argument is
right if you get out you will either
fail to get out in asymmetry at the end
of the argument or you will have cheated
somewhere and smuggled in the asymmetry
but possibly without even noticing it
yourself but you'll have smuggled it in
um just as a matter of logic you can you
can't have an input that doesn't
distinguish a direction of time and have
an output that does distinguish it
so um what do we do what is the right
answer why is there uh what where does
the asymmetry of time
come from then okay so
well i think you can think of three
strategies and one of them we could
probably put aside which is this idea
that it comes from
it comes from something non-physical it
comes from human intervention or
something
so okay i think for our purposes we can
we we can
put that aside and and continue with our
sort of in our physicalist dogma
um within physics if you're going to
break
break that symmetry i think you can only
read logically again you can only read
two ways your dynamics needs to violate
the direction of toughness to
distinguish past the future or your
boundary conditions need to distinguish
past for future
um and so the the former approach needs
to
change change deep physics um
put that aside for the moment that's uh
that's another conversation we have and
it gets on to
something i think we'll talk about later
which is how quantum mechanics plugs
into these questions
assuming you don't want to change the
the microscopic physics you've got to
say something
about um about an appropriate initial
condition
so and what often happens is what you
end up having to do is say something
that gets pushed early in early in time
so let's suppose i do one of these
really innocuous sounding
statements about it's really probable
that the system will
approach um yeah the gather castle
spread out later that's really probable
that entropy will increase etc um if i
place that condition now if i say it's a
condition on the world
now that with really high probability
entropy is going up into the future or
more plausibly if i have some condition
that looks really innocuous
and has that consequence yeah well again
as a matter of time asymmetry time
symmetry it's going to have the same
consequence backwards
and the forward result is what we want
and the backward result is what we don't
want
so you could try doing it earlier you
could say um
maybe i'll impose a bad new condition
100 years ago
that says such as the consequence that
um we would expect um gases to expand
and entropy to go up and so on
now the last hundred years is fine and
now everything we think is
we thought we remembered about
everything prior to 1921 is completely
wrong
so we could put it back a million years
ago and that saves human history but
it's too bad about the dinosaurs
we could put it back um a billion years
ago which is the dinosaurs are fine but
it's too bad about formation the solar
system
uh eventually you end up saying i need
to again if we're sticking with this
sort of broad picture we want to be
reductionist we don't want to
rely on external intervention the only
really place
the real option you've got left is to
put some kind of relevant boundary
condition at the beginning of time
so then you say well the universe or at
least
the bit of the universe we were aware of
the kind of observed cosmos
came into being or very early on was
such that
it has these features whatever they are
that's another conversation
which established that entropy goes up
into the future
and then you've kind of just you just
kind of crossed out
the early a bit so the paradox doesn't
occur
there's a kind of sense in which you you
haven't exactly broken
the the time reversal symmetry and
physics jargon the sixteen past and
future
you've broken the time translation
signature
symmetry the the idea that there's a
there's no preferred moment in a sense
you
you're using the first moment as your
preferred moment
i've always got one sorry i've always
wondered
again an unfair historical question why
didn't boltzmann or someone
in his vicinity propose the big bang
why didn't they take seriously i mean he
did in a paper
suggest that one way out of these
reversibility problems was to have a
special initial condition
but it was really like a sentence in a
paragraph and then he moved on with his
life right and
and no one quite chased that down and
said look you know stars are burning
some
kind of fuel we don't know what it is
but presumably you can't go on forever
there must have been a moment in the
past when things were set up in a
special condition
yeah so historically i have no idea i
mean trying to do a rational
reconstruction
i think part of it is until you've got
the general theory of relativity
um any decision that a particular moment
is the first moment
is just a labeling choice um if you you
you could imagine saying um uh well
this is time equals zero this is the
first moment um
it is forbidden to run the dynamics
backwards from the first moment
but then your graduate student says well
look it's free country and get around
the dynamic back anyway
um and then you've got a perfectly uh
reasonable description because then
you've got you've got effectively uh
a symmetric cosmos that has a big bang
in both directions which is a defensive
you know
i gather some quite smart people have
played with that idea
but it's not it's not a big bang idea
exactly
i think it's when you've got some when
you've got something like gem relativity
on the table you've got the idea that
the theory might enforce the fact that a
moment is first or
as you know not literally at a moment is
first but that there's a
i think that's part of it but i think
also in a way i don't entirely
understand
there was clearly a really strong
philosophical prejudice against the big
bang
i mean the advocates of steady-state
cosmologies
did so quite a long time after the
empirical case for it was looking shaky
they were clearly very philosophically
motivated for it
beyond the date here as everyone who
knows the history of this
at all that yeah einstein could have
predicted the big bang and he instead
cooked up his equations to stop it
happening
there was clearly some something in the
air i don't really understand that made
people
really skeptical about that kind of
beginning of time concept
and this is uh this idea that we need to
set up the initial conditions in a
certain special way i mean number one
it it truly blows my mind even to this
day that the reason why ice cubes melt
and don't unmelt has something to do
with what was going on 14 billion years
ago at the big bang so like i i get a
lot of mileage out of that and i'm still
impressed with myself
and number two uh there's this label for
this idea which is the past hypothesis
and then we argue about what the past
hypothesis really means so
what what is in your mind is uh
why do we call it the past hypothesis
and what is it okay
so the easy answer to why we call it is
because david albert is good with
terminology and came up with this name
well i think you're popularized i'm not
sure
it's basically his language i think um
so that's that's the shallower it's it's
some something
well in the middle version we're just
saying something about the initial
universe
some of the reason it gets talked about
as hypothesis is there's a kind of
tradition of thinking
that uh somehow
the this assumption about the past
is not not supposed to be the kind of
thing we
we might make in the same way we know
other things about the past i mean
somehow it's not just that we like we we
put up a satellite and the satellite
told us something about the early
universe and so we're using that as our
boundary condition it's supposed to be
something more
the it's a pre it's a presupposition for
the applicability of the physics we've
been using including the physics of
satellite assumes
that the very uni early universe has has
this feature
um in terms of what that feature is i
mean that's contentious i mean you know
you and i have been on different sides
of
some academic conversations about this i
mean a very popular idea
is the condition is something like the
very early universe has a very low
entropy
is in a very special state in the um
in the probability sensors i was using
earlier um
there's another sensor which i prefer
which is which is actually something
like that
it's more than the very early universe
is in an appropriate sense not in a
special state it's in a
um it's in a state that doesn't have the
sort of very delicate precise
correlations
between where all the particles are um
that would
be that you weren't in one of these
probable conditions whereby entropy
increases
so just how to cash out this condition
is is a pretty subtle matter i mean you
can
you can kind of work out just by logic
there has to be some condition of that
kind if you're not
if you're not breaking the symmetry in
the dynamics you've got to break it in
the in the boundary conditions
right but quite what the right way to
break it is
um
yeah it it the devil's going to be a
little bit in the details yeah
um i mean maybe this is actually
it's always fun but also dangerous to
get too much into the weeds but maybe
maybe there's a weed or two that we can
get into here because uh
it's worth driving home because even
professional physicists struggle with
this idea
um one way of stating the issue
is that look we have satellites up there
they've taken pictures of the early
universe right the cosmic microwave
background it's very smooth
you know almost homogeneous but with
tiny little ripples in it
and we explained that in terms of the
smooth big bang 14 billion years ago
um and and let's take for granted right
now the idea that
that condition of a hot dense smooth
early universe is low entropy we can
talk about that too but
let's say that is low entropy um
so there's an attitude that would say
look we've taken a picture of it it's
not a hypothesis we have data that says
it was low entropy but then the
much more subtle counter argument is in
the space of all possible ways
that microwave photons could have come
to our telescope
and looked smooth it turns out that most
of them
do not correspond to an early universe
that actually is smooth
right uh there are many many more ways
the early universe could have been
wildly fluctuating
but with very very subtle coincidences
and conspiracies that made the radiation
get to us
and look smooth and it's that kind of
perverse behavior that that you in the
past hypothesis are trying to rule out
is that fair right i think that's fair
although let me let me give a caveat
because i mean i
you you were helping yourself a moment
ago to this kind of well
there's vastly more ways it could be
this than could be that and i was using
that kind of way of talking earlier
but actually i think if you push on this
it starts getting this into trouble
i mean i said sort of flippantly well
there are infinitely many ways the
system could be
so there's no sensor which could be more
more one way than another
but and that's but that is kind of true
in a way and even if there were like
um a million billion gazillion kajillion
ways the system could be but it's finite
it doesn't follow from the fact that
there are a million zillion billion
because kajillion ways a system could be
that it is
equally likely to be each of those ways
i mean i think we've got
a ton of evidence from the actual
application of physics that there's some
robust notion of probability
in statistical mechanics but i also
think we've got quite a lot of reason to
think that that notion of probability is
not something we can get at
a priori from just counting
possibilities
um okay there's something substantive
additional going on the
the assumption is roughly something like
for a given macroscopic way the world
could be
that it's again leaving aside my caveat
about infinity
each of the microscopic ways it could be
conditional with that macroscopic
way it could be is equally likely that's
something like the way of stating it
yeah but it's a it's it's quite a big
step
that's something i think there's
empirical evidence for really at least
with some qualifiers and caveats and
worries about the direction of time
but at some level there's empirical
evidence for it when we make that
assumption
and we derive equations as a result of
that assumption and we check the
experiments in the lab or in the sky
the equations give the answer get the
answer right so that probability
assumption is
is evidenced we don't need to think it
is our priority
the view that somehow if there's lots of
different macroscopic ways a system
could be
then it's more likely to be in the
macroscopic state
that has more microscopic states
corresponding to it well there are
special circumstances in which that's
evidenced as well
when systems have reached equilibrium
when they've had lots of time to
interact and move around the space then
that's then there's evidence that's true
but as a kind of a priori statement
about the world i don't think it's
something we've got evidence for or a
good logical reasoning has to be true
so while in a certain sense you're
clearly right that there are
there are many more ways it's much more
probable that the universe
fluctuated into the way it is right now
rather than the code the satellites gave
us the right answer
there's another sense in which that's
that's non-innocent that there's a
there are some assumptions about how to
think about probability
um that uh that are doing some work in
that argument
long-time mindscape listeners know that
our two cats ariel and caliban are the
real bosses here at mindscape
international headquarters
so we need to keep them happy and sweet
scoop
is the kitty litter that makes that
possible the thing about sweet scoop is
not only that it works as a kitty litter
the cats love it the odor is good the
absorption is good
but it's also environmentally friendly
because sweet scoop
comes from wheat rather than from clay
wheat it turns out has naturally
occurring starches and enzymes that
actively break things down
it's low dust low tracking and easy to
dispose of
and unlike clay based litter sweet scoop
is a hundred percent biodegradable
for over 25 years sweet scoop has
provided a litter that works great
without compromising on what matters
100 natural ingredients and 99.5
dust free so if you're stuck between
litter that works and litter that's pet
and planet friendly
sweet scoop doesn't make you choose go
to sweetscoop.com to get a 5
off coupon and find a retailer near you
to get the spelling right that's
s-w-h-e-a-t-scoop.com
sweetscoop.com
i think i think that's perfectly fair uh
if if maybe a little bit persnickety but
that is your professional job right i
mean you're a philosopher so that's okay
it's pretty much a job description yeah
exactly we're not gonna hold that
against you but
so let me just rephrase it very quickly
just so you know we we keep
separate like what the contentious parts
are and what the parts everyone agrees
with are i mean
you're probably right that since since
i'm my job description is physicist and
not philosopher i speak sloppily that's
my job description
right so i used the word probability
where i really meant you know number of
different states or something like that
um i i do think that there's that
philosophers can sometimes be
too persnickety about counting the
number of different states i think
there's a perfectly obvious way to count
the number of different states
and that doesn't mean that it's a
probability distribution that doesn't
mean that you know in penrose's famous
formulation that god
threw a dartboard randomly at that space
of states but there remains the fact
that uh the past hypothesis needs to
have some way of saying that in the
space of all the different ways
the universe could have been there's a
measure there's a way of counting and
our real universe was in a very very
tiny region
in that space and that needs to that's
the past hypothesis broadly construed
yeah okay so
i don't think this is just um just
penetrate i think we actually disagree
with
some something substantive here i mean
so
there's there's a well-known way of
stating the past hypothesis that says
something like you said there that the
early universe
the hypothesis is that the early
universe was in a was in a
a very low energy state or a certain
particular state that is in fact very
low entropy
um and that if one assumes that then one
gets the direction of time right
i actually think that's the wrong way to
state the hypothesis um
uh and one way of getting at that is i
think um
this is like like a minor bit of it
i mean however um
however low entropy the initial universe
was in
it could have ended up in an even lower
entropy state later the the the
the issues about time reversibility are
still there i mean
let's suppose that the earlier well okay
so firstly actually let's say the
yeah the overview this was very hot and
very dense and we want us and we we've
established that we think that's a low
entropy state
it's still a sense in which um you know
it it could have been hotter and denser
and it would be lower or could be hotter
it would be lower entropy so there's a
certain way there but but more seriously
suppose that was a very low entropy
state there's still a way in which it
could have fluctuated to an even lower
energy state
right so we don't rule out that
possibility
just by specifying this very low entropy
initial stage
um we have to say something else and the
something else i think
takes the form actually helped myself to
the physicist's sloppiness
that that given that initial state it
was it was equally likely to be in any
of the microscopic states
corresponding to it and so it was super
unlikely to be in one of the
fluctuating to an even lower entropy
state yeah but my feeling is once you've
said that once you've said okay
given the macrostate of the early
universe it was equally likely to be in
in any other of the microstates go
compatible with it i don't think
anything more is gained at least for the
purpose of explaining the arrow of time
in the here and now
by saying and what's more that state was
a really low entropy state
i mean if it was a really high entropy
state the world would not look like this
but it's also true that if the world was
in a state with a different kind of
better anti-matter ratio it'd also not
look like this um
the the the the smoothness of the early
universe explains lots of things about
the here and now
um but i'm not compelled by the argument
that it explains the
the time directedness of our microscopic
physics so let me see so
in other words you're saying um so
actually
let's back up a little bit there's the
idea of a macro state which we sort of
glossed over and
people want to make a big deal about
this and i think it's proper to make a
big deal about this so one of
boltzmann's genius moves was to say
look you know there's atoms molecules
they're moving around
uh but i can't see what the atoms
molecules are so i'm going to group
them all the atoms molecules that look
similar into
a single group that i'll call a macro
state i don't know if you use those
words but that's what we do
and so people have been asking so i will
ask you
like what's the license to do that is
that okay is that objective or is
your human agency sneaking its way in
here something subjective
good yeah i mean the words get used to
kind of different ways and i think one
of them
should worry reductionist naturally so
one of them basically shouldn't
and the one that should worry people is
the one that defines macroscopic in
terms of our own abilities to
distinguish them
so you want to say well the the reason
why
um um
why uh we we treat two different
configurations of gas
in the room as being the same macrostate
is something like we can't distinguish
between them with our eyes or sometimes
even like
uh we're only interested in the gas um
at the level of a coarse graining as you
know like like a microscopic description
but you know i mean hashtag embarrassing
um confessions i don't actually care
about the gas at all
with the old the minimal requirements to
be able to breathe i don't really mind
where the air in my room is
it's still true that that um the
thermodynamics describes it fairly well
even though i'm not curious about it
and and similarly we use statistical
mechanics to describe
um even things like the way galaxies and
stars in the galaxy develop
and we can obviously just um you know
telescopes can tell us where the damn
stars are
and yet we still want to dump various
clearly visibly distinct
arrangements of stars into the same
macro state and say what we care about
is um the average distribution of the
stars or something yeah so
so i think the the good notion of
macrostate the one that the
the naturalist can be relaxed about is
something like
this is a level of description at which
you can get some kind of robust
autonomous in the philosopher's jargon
sense self-contained
dynamical story so it's a if i
if i want to know uh how the air in the
room is going to revolve over the next
five minutes
um at a certain coarse grain description
it it turns out that all i need to know
about the air now
is again at a certain well modulo these
worries about thermodynamics so
just empirically it's true that i can
make reliable predictions about what the
air will do
at a certain course level um provided i
know what the air is doing now
at a certain cause level uh and you know
we we have equations that say what water
does
that don't require us to say where all
the individual molecules are
we can we can do we could do higher
level science and
the macrostates are the way of breaking
up the lower level stuff into higher
level stuff such that you can do high
level science
that's the robust version i think that
we we shouldn't be suspicious about
um yeah go ahead sorry i just guess i i
mean that uh
feeds into not just statistical
mechanics but bigger
issues of emergence and damage
uh former mindscape guest has this
wonderful phrase
real patterns that you also uh that you
make use of in the in the uh case of the
everett interpretation i mean
the fact that you don't need to know
absolutely everything about the universe
but you can have incomplete information
and still in the right circumstances
make predictions about it is an
objective fact about the universe and
that's what we appeal to in this sort of
boltzmann course graining
yeah absolutely and it's a solid effect
the reductionism itself
i mean it's just empirically true that
we can write down reliable equations for
what gases do
it didn't have to be that way now you
know if you can
often we found those equations because
we did microphysics and worked it out
but not always and even if we'd done the
microphysics work it out we could have
thrown it away
and still check the equations they were
still right right um so
you know it's insofar as your best
theory of microphysics
says it's not possible to have equations
of that form so much the worse for your
best theory of microphysics
we we are actual evidence for our
microscopic physics mostly doesn't come
from
microscopic measurements mostly it comes
from these millions of
intermediate calculations we have from
the
we talk about the standard model
explaining everything or underpinning
everything there's almost no experiment
that counts as a systematic test of the
standard model as a whole
there are as you well know there are
approximations
and chains of approximations that
approximations that ground
all the various ways these theories work
and the evidence the first order
evidence is the evidence that these
various approximations are right and
because they're right then and that
gives some support for the
the theory for which we derive them but
really the world we find empirically in
the first order
is a world just full of all of these
different processes different levels
that we think are connected and we've
got i think we've got a good reason to
think connected
but which we have evidence for even if
they're not connected good
and specifically so there is some sort
of objectiveness to the coarse graining
that we choose in practice and
specifically
because some of my favorite super smart
cosmologists don't understand this
the early universe has a low entropy in
those
in that core screening uh there's this
feeling that you say something like
look it's just a black body radiation
that's high entropy you know how could
it
it it had the highest entropy it could
have had
given that it was tiny um but when you
turn on gravity that's not true so
i mean am i right to say that the earl
it's fair to say that early universe had
low entropy compared to what it could
have had
and gravity has something to do with it
here's something i don't understand
about this
these conversations with cosmologists i
mean absolutely the early universe
had low entropy compared to what it
could have but
one really great way to tell that is i
mean the early universe had low entropy
compared to the current universe i mean
if it
if it didn't the second law of
thermodynamics is apparently wrong
and no other things that well yes so
it would really better be the case that
the early universe was it was lower
entry in the present universe we
shouldn't need to give some subtle
transfer deadly argument as to why it
must have must
be lower it'd better be lower in order
not to blow our entire thermodynamic
theory out of the water
but to be fair the the argument which is
completely wrong but still the it's not
it's not completely nonsensical is that
there's sort of an envelope of maximum
possible entropy yeah just because the
universe was smaller and sort of it was
the argument is that it was as high
entropy as it could have been
even though it's lower entropy than now
um but
even that argument is totally wrong
because it ignores gravity in black
holes and things like that
yeah although i i mean it does but i i
i'd also say look it
it actually ignores the fact the
universe is expanding and i think even
that homogenous piece of it in some ways
like smooth is enough to do the work
we need of it here i mean the the the
very early universe was in
this equilibrium thermal state then it
expanded
um and that was the it was the hot that
was the highest energy it could be given
the other constraints on it
and given that it was uniform given that
this uniform is a huge constraint
absolutely but but look
go go forward a little while and it's
still uniform but it's no longer the
highest entropy it could be
um you know there comes a point where
all the quark gluon slash has turned
into neutrons and protons
and there comes a further point when
some of the neutrons and protons have
fused into helium
so there there comes a point when it's
about three-quarters hydrogen and one
quarter helium
and then it stops there and it carries
on being three-quarters hydrogen and one
quarter helium
if it had um if it had wanted state
equilibrium it wouldn't have done that
right the the equilibrium condition for
the universe
uh this is more your territory than mine
but like well
well before it gets gets non-homogenous
on large scales it was
it was the the equilibrium configuration
would have been all helium
that's right um and it wasn't all helium
um
why well it was expanding so fast that
um
the particles got too far apart before
they finish crashing into each and after
making him
so i mean i just used that as a
illustration the
you're absolutely right of course about
the fact that gravity and things not
being uniform mean
that the real story about entropy in in
gravitating systems is just radically
different from non-gravitating systems
but even at a more basic level than that
trying to apply
kind of equilibrium arguments to a
system that is very rapidly expanding
is itself really dubious really rapidly
expanding systems are not at equilibrium
and the universe's macro conditions were
changing very fast so it was only ever
reasonable to suppose it was some kind
of local equilibrium there's there's
some there's a
you can think about the universe while
it's still uniform as being sort of like
a piston if
if i put some very hot gas in a piston
and i expanded it very gently
then the gas would always stay
instantaneously equilibrium and if your
piston was like ridiculously strong
you could compress it you could expand
it from being a quiet glue on plasma
all the way to being cold iron and it
would all be equilibrium
if you pull the piston apart a bit
faster than that then
it'll freeze out at some mixture of
stuff
that hasn't finished going to
equilibrium it did because it was
expanding and it was expanding too
quickly
and so i think those things are going on
in the early universe
even before you start considering um
gravity and effects of gravity and you
know non-uniform distributions
and what do you think that the the earth
is powered by fusion from the sun and
the fusion of the sun is possible
because
uh there's there was lots of hydrogen
left over from the big bang
um which wouldn't have been left over if
the universe had stayed at equilibrium
as long as it was uniform then you
realize that um
the the thermodynamics of the the
present day
actually rests on some of these factors
as much as it rests on
issues that non-uniform systems are
higher energy so i i
i i'm tempted to go back into the weeds
on the past hypothesis definition but i
i worry that we're getting too much into
the weeds on that there's a lot of
non-weeds things that i want to get
well i i think there's a rather unfair
thing i'm doing here which is this is
actually a place where we have a
some minor but quite interesting
intellectual differences and i'm pushing
my side against your position as a
podcast host who
can't kind of fire back with the
fulfillment you totally are and i might
i'm not even sure whether i disagree
with you or not so we should have
an offline discussion and then we'll
we'll put it somewhere on the internet
to
reward we'll make it as a reward for the
patreon subscribers or something like
that um
but but okay but you said something that
i think is very important to this bigger
picture
discussion um
the universe expands there's this
competition between
things trying to equilibrate photons and
electrons and protons and neutrons and
helium
versus the fact that universe is
expanding and so it doesn't stay in
equilibrium because otherwise like you
said the hydrogen would just
keep fusing the helium would keep using
you would all
create all the the elements up to iron
and then then you would stop there
uh so the the sort of hidden fact that
is relevant there is that even though
the second law says entropy increases
there's no law that says entropy
increases as fast as possible
right i mean sometimes people try to
invoke laws like that
in living systems or dissipative systems
or something like that i mean
how just very very big picture how far
do you think we can go beyond the second
law to be quantitative about
the ways in which entropy increases yeah
so i'm not sure they're not even sure
entropy is always the reliable language
to use here
i mean we have so one of the things i
tend to do as a as a philosopher physics
is try sometimes to step down a little
bit from the big picture of how this
could possibly work
and say well what are the ways in which
it's actually been work being done and
what are the assumptions that are going
into them
so we've got a very developed theory of
of non-equilibrium
statistical mechanics in the jargon of
the of the physics of systems that
aren't
equilibrium um and are genuinely
changing at time but are big enough that
you need to use these kind of averaging
methods
of statistical mechanics of
thermodynamics to study them
and what you find in those stories is
that entropy
mostly seems to be a bookkeeping device
you can tell reliable stories about
irreversibility
and normally those are processes in
which the entropy of the system's going
up but when they're not it's only
because there's some environment that's
absorbing the entropy cast
but the actual the dynamic it's not like
well in in the language i was using
earlier about robust autonomous
structures we don't there seem to have a
robust autonomous dynamics of entropy
right um you need to know more about the
system than just its entropies know what
it's going to do
and different systems do radically
different things and there doesn't seem
to be any general law that systems want
to
really go directly at all i mean here's
a sort of
an example that it's at an abstract
level has just the same structure as the
hydrogen helium example but it's perhaps
easier people to grasp
if i take a box and i fill it with
a mixture of hydrogen gas and oxygen gas
or a glass jar or something and i leave
that on my shelf it can sit there for
years and be perfectly happy in there
and
if you think equilibrium is the state
that things make their way to fairly
quickly and then stay there
you might be forgiven for thinking that
that box of a mixture of hydrogen and
oxygen is at equilibrium
but if you strike a match you'll find
that you'll really quickly realize it
was not an equilibrium
and it's much more entropically
favorable much more thermodynamically
favorable for the hydrogen oxygen to
react inform water and blow your lab up
but um there just happens to be a
dynamical bar
to us getting and it's it's not um
it's not a mysterious bar it's about the
fact that the tip the typical energies
of
there's a certain amount of energy of
which hydrogen oxygen need to crash
together in order to turn to water
and that typical energy is much higher
than the typical energy of actual
hydrogen oxygen in the gas uh and so
typically just bounce off each other and
keep going if you waited really really
long times it would happen
but it's just not going to happen
spontaneously in the time scale
when you're sitting in the room um so we
understand at some level we understand
the physics of that fine
but the point is it's that specifics of
the physics that tells us that this
system
yeah it does not have increasing entry
so they can't i take from examples of
that kind that
there can't be there can't be uniform
or universal principles about how
quickly entropy increases or something
that doesn't that's not to say that
there might not be
powerful generalizations that are not
universal but nonetheless
have a universality in physics jargon
apply to a very large class of systems
as far as i can see we don't
very systematically have things of that
kind
so far but that doesn't tell us anything
about whether we could have things with
that gun
so i don't know i mean this is more um
that that kind of what what are the most
promising routes to develop an exciting
new piece of physics is a place where i
uh have to submit a subject center now
outside my comfort zone so
i uh i'm not sure
there are some things you just can't do
from the comfort of home you can't go on
a hike
you can't go see a concert but what you
can do
is exercise and with peloton you'll have
a workout experience
like no other without ever leaving home
one of the great things about peloton is
the feeling
that you're in a community that there
are other people participating
struggling and sweating
along with you so even though you have
the convenience of being at your own
home
you get the common feeling that everyone
is in this together
from keeping up with close friends to
enjoying world-class workouts with
people around the globe
you'll never work out alone you can hand
out high fives on the leaderboard and
join groups like working moms a peloton
or tabata for tacos so with the peloton
bike there's nothing like working out
from home
learn more at one peloton.com
new members can try peloton classes free
for 30 days
at one peloton dot com slash app terms
apply
that's o n e p e l o t
dot it's an excellent point to make
that you know okay there's the second
law and entropy goes up
but that doesn't mean that entropy is
necessarily the best thing to be keeping
track of when you're trying to formulate
these rules and in fact i would spin it
in a positive way as saying
as a researcher like there's a lot of
landscape out there for potential
discoveries of better ways to state
these universal rules that we don't have
non-equilibrium
uh changes in statistical mechanics is
is a is a rapidly growing field right
now and sort of has been
sadly neglected in the previous century
so i'm optimistic about that
well good so this is a good sort of
segue then into
these uh remaking the connections we
started with
to other arrows of time so we have a
complicated universe full of all sorts
of different things
with manifest manifestations i should
say of
time asymmetry which we're going to say
are ultimately due to
let's say let's call the thermodynamic
arrow of time you know the fact that uh
entropy is increasing however you want
to characterize that error of time so
why does the fact that ice cubes melt
and don't unmelt
help me understand why i remember the
past but not the future or why i get
older as time goes on
yeah i'm not sure i know the right
general thing to say here
um and i think a lot of the attempts to
say it have never been
i never found completely compelling um
i mean look here's a starting point that
i think matters the when we talk about
the way in which the physics
distinguishes the past from the future
um sometimes
we characterize that as just there isn't
a symmetry that reflects past and future
but that
that i think doesn't fully get at it i
mean there are you know as you know
there are there are microscopy bits of
physics that in a certain sense
genuinely break the symmetry of past and
future the
the decay of neutrons in a certain way
um or that certain
so rather more ester in that i guess
actually for that symmetry
esoteric bits of particle physics
actually seem to break the past future
symmetry but not in the way that matters
from this point of view not in my
if you ran the video backwards would it
be manifestly obvious that you were
doing anyway
what what i think matters in the way
these dynamics run
differently forward and backwards is the
they have irreversibility and they have
noise irreversibility meaning
um you lose information lots lots of
different
initial states come together and end up
in the same final stage
um noise in the sense that it becomes
at least de facto impossible to predict
which of many
future states the system's going to make
its way into
um and those those features of
irreversibility and noise um
wash out information in the evolution
process
um so
you sort of see this if you look at
predicting forward and backwards if i
if i've got something like the solar
system physics like i was saying for
eclipses the way i
the way i go about predicting what the
solar system will be like in a thousand
years time is exactly the same as the
way in which we predict
the well retro dip to use the target the
way the world will be
was a thousand years ago and we say rep
this funny neologism retrodict in this
situation
because we really are just doing a
prediction just with time set as
negative
you can't mostly you can't retrodict um
macroscopic laws if i've got the the ice
cubes in isolation or i've got my let's
say
i've got my cup of um with a little bit
of ice and there's cold water
around it um i can predict pretty
reliably
the rate at which that ice cube will
melt and the length of time at which the
ice cube has gone
entirely i can't retradict that way i
can't work out
um whether actually the ice cube
what which ice cubes were there before
how they were put in
that information is just lost maybe the
microphysics still still knows it but
the
at the level of description we're
talking about it's just gone so i think
at some level
these kind of ways in which our dynamics
are irreversible information losing
um are also in the business of
distributing stuff across space
in a way and not bringing them back in
um
these are the kind of features of
dynamics that then suggest that if you
try to build things in dynamics if you
try to do information processing in that
dynamics
that information processing is also
going to have to have a
a clear distinction but in the way it
treats the past and treats the future so
that's the proof of concept
i don't think i've ever worked out fully
to my satisfaction how the details of
that are going to go you know what
why does that general asymmetry of
information processing specifically lead
to the fact that we're
putting down records about the past and
making
partially reliable predictions about the
future and not very fair so i think the
the quick attempts to do is you're not
convincing um okay
the convincing attempts aren't fully
there i mean the the there seems to be
at least a naive tension between what
you said which is certainly true about
the fact that
there's dissipation and we lose
information in some real sense with the
fact that
as a real person i think that i'm
learning things as time goes on and i
am writing books and there's information
in the books and so
there's some local increase in the
amount that i know
about the past and that's clearly going
to be a little bit tricky to reconcile
yeah and look i mean i guess you know of
course um
by the same token there's an apparent
tension it's long been recognized some
some people who shouldn't know better if
used to argue against science or for all
sorts of executions
it's long be the case that um there's
the parent tension between
the fact that entropy always seems to go
up and the fact that we go towards
equilibrium
and the fact that i personally am not a
decorative woman don't expect to be
against
him for some decades right um uh and of
course the answer to that is
unmysterious i'm not a closed system
i can maintain my own low entropy by
dumping uh entropy into the world around
me just like my fridge can stay cold by
warming up the room
and at some level these kind of
information processing things have the
same answer i think you can uh
even if the physical process that going
on are systematically
it subs is losing information um then
uh i could still provide it provided i
don't mind
dumping the world into randomized states
um i can still maintain
an increasing information about the
things that interest me which brings up
a related worry that people
often try to pinpoint me with you know
if you think that
all of the differences between past and
future ultimately come from this
thermodynamic gradient
uh if if someone puts you in a
refrigerator and your entropy starts
going down do you suddenly remember the
future but not the past i mean is it
possible to sort of
completely reverse the arrow of time
locally
in a way that would make physics seem
very weird yeah
well not by putting you in the
refrigerator i mean um
well it kind of goes a bit to what we
were saying earlier about entropy not
necessarily being the sole measure of
irreversibility
yeah i mean there are a ton of
irreversible processes in your body
and even if you're cooling down so that
your overall entropy is decreasing
those processes are still happening
irreversibly the dynamics that's
governing all of the kind of
biology in your cells is still happening
in a way that draws a clear past future
distinction
now if you did something to you that
systematically reversed
those directions that's another matter
but now you won't do that by the fridge
now we need kind of space aliens and god
like science to do it
and we kind of know what would happen if
you would run backwards you'd um and if
your environment was preserved so if
your environment was preserved to be
compatible with it then obviously it
would just be like
what leaving aside i think a slightly
badly phrased quest about what they'll
be like subjectively then from the point
of view of the
of the person watching you would just do
everything backwards right um
but that's that's obviously we set the
problem up that way that's trivial um
if your environment was not also running
backwards i think you probably i think
extremely quickly the environment would
mess up would mess with um the way you
were trying to run backwards and start
you running forwards again yeah
so this crude kind of thing like just
lowering your entropy overall
is not nearly enough to truly reverse
your personal error of time
exactly all the very if what we're
really after here is dynamically
reversibility then the dynamically
reversible processes are not
are not changed by eventually it's going
all
in entropy terms all of those processes
are still generating their entropy
and we're also swagging a big chunk of
entropy out of your system just by
just by moving bits of your body that
are locally at equilibrium
to bits of your body that are at local
equilibrium at a lower temperature
and that overall entry budget which is a
sum
of the various non-equilibrium bits of
your body doing non-equilibrium stuff
that increases entropy
plus um the um
uh the the the disorderly cooling down
bits of you
all of that's going to be positive going
to be negative cellular entropy drops
but
it's still the case that dynamics in
your body is cleanly distinguished
between past and future
it's just that that crude indicator of
which was the entropy gradient going
uh is isn't doing it for you there's
more to thermodynamically reversibility
than just the entropy gradient
well you know i i believe everything you
just said but i think you're missing a
big opportunity for a startup that would
not only
preserve you in time but actually make
you younger just by putting you in a
refrigerator like if you could
develop some theory of that you could be
making boku box i'm just saying
uh if it worked i think i could make a
lot of that if i could convince people
it would work i could be making almost
as much money if i'm a little bit too
honest
if the convincing people works is an
easier task in making it work so i think
that's
that's the whole secret to being in this
in this business but
okay all right with good with all that
wonderful stuff on the table
um there is a a looming specter uh
over this whole discussion which is that
we've been speaking pretty classically
right uh good old we even mentioned
isaac newton and maxwell and people like
that
and there's a famous part of physics
where it does not seem
manifestly time symmetric which is the
act of observation and the collapse of
the wave function in quantum mechanics
so you know something about quantum
mechanics uh how do you think about
i mean either generally or you're very
happy to dive right into
uh everett in many worlds if you want
but how do you think about
the time asymmetry of measurement in
quantum theory
good okay so my starting point is going
to be that same kind of dynamics first
broadly reductionist starting point that
i think we just sort of took as a common
starting point an hour ago
um and that's going to be so measurement
here is just a special case
of large-scale interaction measurements
happen when some
relatively small-scale thing gets
magnified up in a highly redundant way
so the processes of measurement from
that point of view
are going to have to be special cases of
this process of being magnified to the
to the macroscopic
but of course famously in quantum
mechanics that process is problematic
um uh the
the process of of measurement of
macroscopic amplification
de facto looks something like the
randomized collapse of the wave function
it
it as a practical matter it looks as if
what was originally a superposition of
lots of possible goings on
snaps into being one of them um
what's really going on to justify that
is another matter but that's kind of how
it
how it just looks from the point of view
of doing the practical physics
um the the emergent level description is
a description where i
move from a superposition to a randomly
selected element of the superposition
but that process is blatantly manifestly
time
irreversible um and it's always amazed
me actually it's less true that used to
be but for a long time always amazed me
that that kind of quantum mechanical
error of time
was the sort of i don't know the
forgotten step child
of the areas of time and physics um it
got very little airtime compared to the
um
the the other the sexier hours of time
if you like but um
but really it's because you say quantum
mechanics is kind of fundamental
it really ought to kind of matter here
that it's turning up um
and i think the reason why it doesn't
well
there's a state there's a claimed reason
why people don't worry about these
quantum effects and there's a real
reason i think that
the um uh the claimed reason is
something like there'll be a standard
line you'll get to the beginning of
almost any
sort of textbook of philosophy of cisco
mechanics it'll say something like
yes i'm using classical mechanics yes
the veil is really quantum
yes we better allow for the quantum
effects but quantum mechanics is
technically the
constant statistical mechanics is
technically more complicated than
classical statistical mechanics
and the same foundation essentially the
same foundational issues arise
i've that is i think
just almost exactly wrong as a statement
of what's going on i think
i think i think actually for
foundational purposes i mean i won't go
to the details because addition to the
weeds for foundational processes quantum
mechanics is easier
there's a bunch of there's a bunch of
pathological features of classical
mechanics that are not present
in quantum mechanics but i mean if you
want to calculate that sure how to help
you but if you want to just work out the
abstract structure of the problem
it is easier to be quantum um and and
the and the issues change
um profoundly um for a bunch of reasons
and i'm sure we'll come on to more of
them but but in the first instance just
precisely because of this clear
asymmetry of the
of measurement of microscopic um
amplification
i think the real reason people who write
textbooks on this stuff or monographs on
this stuff
do classical statistical mechanics
because they're scared of the quantum
measurement problem
and they don't want their beautiful
pieces about physical mechanics to be
adulterated by all of this quantum
mechanical stuff
i mean i i would agree with that if we
interpreted the word
scared as uh having a concern that it
would derail the entire discussion
that's fair yeah and i think the problem
is it does derail the entire discussion
but that's another way of saying that
quantum mechanics is really important to
understand the statistical cataclysm
um but i suppose put it this way look at
that um
that asymmetry we're talking about um
that asymmetry cannot clearly be
distinguished from the statistical
mechanical asymmetry
it's not exactly the same as it but it's
intimately related to it
um uh if you i mean
there's a bunch of different ways of
seeing it but um if you think that for
instance almost every
if you think the that the the collapse
of the wave function is a genuinely
random process
at a really deep level for instance it
more or less it always destroys any
concerns that i can run my probability
argument just as well forward and
backwards
if if it's extremely probable that the
current state will evolve into higher
energy state
but there are certain super special ways
that the current state could be
that um could have evolved into a low
entropy state well
even if even if you put the system on
these super special states it's not
going to stay there for long because
quantum randomness will just kick it
around a bit
so if you had fundamental collapse of
the wave function
you would break the asymmetry and time
of the dynamics in a way that it's
heuristically really plausible would
would sort out statistical mechanics
now if i thought claps of the wave
function was a good idea then i could go
on a sub length with how we could reform
systems without things
i think for reasons that i think you
share but this is a terrible idea or
it's a good it's a good idea it's it's a
fundamentally wrong idea but it doesn't
work
it's not the right way to go the right
way to go i think is something like the
many worlds interpretation
we want to say that quantum mechanics
really maintains all those
superpositions
and the fact that it looks as if we've
got one of the possible
outcomes at all at once rather than all
of them at the same time is perspective
it's the
we just happen to be the kind of
physical system that's sitting in one of
those
those terms there's a there's a david in
one of the other branches after a
quantum measurement
who's just as committed to being david
as i'm committed
um and of course there's a whole
panoply of issues associated to many
wells quantum mechanics anyway but to
stick with the
statistical mechanical issues um many
worlds quantum mechanics is
has is time-reversal variant variant
because it's just unitary
schrodinger equation quantum mechanics
it's got it's reversible in the previous
senses
and so there isn't any prospect in many
worlds quantum mechanics
of having some prior quantum error of
time
that underpins the the classic the
statistical mechanical area of time
in a sense it's almost the other way
around if you look at the kind of
mathematics that's used to describe um
uh measurement and the the amplification
of superpositions to the macroscopic
and the thing that quantum physicist
called coherence where
it becomes impossible in practice to
detect the many worlds nature
of systems because they get so tangled
up with their environment
if you look at the actual mathematics of
all of that it's all statistical
mechanical the kind of assumptions made
to derive those equations
are just the same assumptions as we use
to derive the equations in
num equilibrium statistical mechanics in
fact sometimes they're literally the
same equations
there's a you know there is a thing that
people
in d coherence theory and foundations of
quantum mechanics use um
you know the the d coherence master
equation first
standard models of how the environment
defects involve model system this
is literally the same as a standard
equation that's used in
um non-equilibrium mechanics and has
been used from the
60s and 70s there's nothing untoward
there no one's denying that but it's
surprisingly often not recognized
because the people
working on one side of that divide
aren't super familiar with work on the
other side
either way i i yeah i i met that
equation as a grad student interesting
quantum mechanics in the 90s in the
leaky hills literature it was 20 years
before i rediscovered
well yeah so i think we can take on
board
the idea that our listeners um
know what that there's something called
quantum mechanics and there's a wave
function as a superposition of different
things and even that they can
that they know that you and i are both
fans of the many worlds interpretation
which says that like you say collapses
aren't real
uh there's just this smooth reversible
evolution of the wave function
okay but then there's branching right
and i think that's and this is exactly
where the time asymmetry comes in
yes but maybe before the time asymmetry
we should
ask because this is a crucial question
and and i try my best to give good
answers to it but it doesn't always
satisfy people
what do you mean by branching when does
that happen how often does it happen how
should i think about that
good good okay so so to back up a little
bit um
here's how i think about it if you if
people listen carefully i'm going to
smuggle in a whole bunch of assumptions
about the direction of time that we'll
need to come back
but ignoring that for the moment um
so what's going on when we
measure a system or we allow a
microscopic system to magnify up to the
macroscopic
is effectively that lots and lots and
lots of other bits of the world
get tangled up get quantum entangled
questions
so the kind of full experiment i always
start with i've got i've got something
like shredding his cat and scherdinger's
cat is alive and dead at the same time
um and the normal form of the quantum
measurement problem says
that's um uh that's um
yeah that that can't be the way things
are because when i look at cats i never
see them alive and dead at the same time
and some of the background there is the
idea that what it would be like to
see a cattle life and dead at the same
time is kind of like what it was like in
the four days before the pandemic where
you just got really drunk with friends
and
you were so drunk you saw double yeah um
but somehow seeing a cat alive and at
the same time would be like having a
an experience of seeing a really weird
indefinite cat um
that's intuitively what it would be like
to see a cat that's lagging at the same
time
intuition's a really bad way to work out
how things look in the physical theory
if you ask the physics what it would
look like well if i look at a like a cat
that's alive that's just a physical
process
so my brain goes into some state or my
body goes to some state you might
describe it as a seeing a live cat stage
and if i see a dead cat then i go into a
state that you might describe as seeing
a dead cat's day
so what it's a this churning equation is
is linear so what that means is if i
never mind the details of that it means
if i
if i look at a cat that's live and dead
at the same time then
my state after that is seeing a live cat
and seeing a dead cat
at the same time i i'm not myself in
some definite state of seeing a weird
indefinite cat
i myself in an indefinite state between
two
rather mundane cat-seeing experiences
and the cat's connected up so the
me and the cat together are jointly in a
state of cat alive i see live cat
plus cat dead i see dead cat and if i
then tell you on the podcast whether the
cat's alive or not
um then you end up in being told it's
alive and being told it's dead state at
the same time
and your listeners when it's played i
mean much sooner than this really but
in in fantasy for the raven your
listeners when it's played
um uh
are in a being told by sean the cat's
alive plus being told sean's
by sean the cat's dead state at the same
time and again it's all correlated to
the whole quantum state of me and you
and the cat and your listeners
is a sum of two things both of which are
ordinary one of them
is the cat's alive i told you the cat's
alive and you and and you broadcast on
the internet
and the other one is the cat's dead i
told you the cat's dead and you that
brought the internet
and the rest of the world it's as they
hear about and find out we get entangled
although the reality actually is um it's
faster and less picturesque than that
the
the ordinary kind of electromagnetic
disruptions and things for me
doing this will spread out at the speed
of light and put you in a state
of at the same time being correlated
with david seeing a live cat and being
correlated david seeing dedicate even
before
you're consciously aware of the answer
to that so
the the earth as a whole the solar
system as a whole pretty soon
is at the same time cat alive
and all and catalyzed goings on and cat
dead cat dead goings on
and each of those terms separately is
not interacting with the other one in
any meaningful sense
they're not the way in which quantum
quantum superpositions quantum two
things that once show up as two things
at once
is through interference effects that we
can do between the two
which um whereby somehow things can
reinforce or cancel
out so somehow uh the live cat bits
could cancel out from the details if
it's good vehicles that can't happen
here
um the one systems get big enough this
is more thermodynamic irreversibility
actually but once the systems get big
enough
you um you just can't do those kind of
interference there are too many moving
parts to
to um to mesh up like that so so what
you've really got is two
um two chunks of physical reality each
each one is not interacting um with the
other one
and each one looks like structurally is
isomorphic two has the same shape as
what things would be like if an ordinary
definite classical thing was going on
so the world is two ordinary classical
definite things going on at the same
time um
and we need all the universes and we
need a term for some big chunk of
reality
that's doing its own thing and not
really interacting with other big chunks
of reality
world and branch are quite good terms
for that yeah but they're emergent i
mean my book on this is the emergent
multiverse it's not the
sort of fundamental of the other deepest
level of reality multiverse the
all of this kind of multiple things
happen at the same time is just
more of that higher level autonomous
goings on that we were talking about
earlier in the podcast it's just there's
more than one bit of it at a time
right and and actually it's worth saying
for potential skeptics in the audience
if you signed on to the previous
discussion about these emergent
structures and how they could have
autonomous laws then
you're most of the way to signing on to
the many world's interpretation of
quantum mechanics it's a very similar
absolutely thing yeah i mean this is one
of my original arguments for
for many worlds in philosophy like way
back when i was kind of making that jump
from being a physics graduate student
that
once you accepted the freight the basic
rules of how emergence worked in physics
um and you applied them to unitary
unmodified quantum mechanics
the many worlds just more or less
happened they weren't something you put
into the theory they were just given to
you structurally
by the way it was set up and so so
conversely
if you were positive you if you want to
reject the evident interpretation
um you're in some danger of
of rejecting rather general rules about
how
theories at different levels are related
and rules that we use
pretty much all labor science if we rule
such that if we didn't use them
a lot of science would just stop working
but now i get to ask you like all these
tricky annoying questions because you
helped yourself to a very simple example
of ferninger's cat which by the way
uh fans of the mindscape podcast can buy
a t-shirt with freudinger's cat on it
at the mindscape merch store
although my cat is alive it's awakened
asleep versus alive in a dead because i
don't like to kill the cat well you have
cats david exactly
yeah so you know there's room for people
but
when the observational outcome is not
something that only has two possible
outcomes but it's continuous like the
position of a particle
uh is branching happening all the time
and can we even count
the number of branches yeah and
i don't think we can count them or at
least we can't we can't count them down
arbitrarily
i mean look the cat is an example of
this really um i'm going to stick with
the brutal version of the original shirt
who's catholicism cat lovers i mean
there are many ways in which that
cyanide capsule can break right
and um and come to that there are many
times in which the event can happen but
the way people tend to tell
schoeninger's cat in in in physics
classes these days is you make a
measurement of some particle
and according to the outcome the cat
lives or dies it's very clean it's very
discreet but
schrodinger's original one had a
radioisotope yeah so we didn't actually
get
um a discrete breaking into live cat and
dead cat we got a live cat
plus a kind of continuum worth of dying
of dying cats who die at different times
so how do you analyze that um
in the kind of emergent story i was
telling well you can't literally treat
us as a continuum
if you if you want to say that
you know take take two i want to
separate the various
dead states into states that differ by
you know i don't know 10 to the minus 25
seconds
yeah so that won't work there's on those
time scales the kind of quantum
coherence of the radioactive decay
matters
i can't uh i the
the the degree to which um you know the
wavelength of the decayed particles
requires constructive interference to
make sense of it means if you
if you try to break the world up onto
worlds that are that finely grained then
my claim earlier on that there's no
interaction between these wells no
interference effects between them stops
being true
at that grain of analysis there's
interference
so i can't think of the the cat
state as being decomposed into branches
that differ by 10 to the minus 25
seconds
i slightly pull that number out of the
air if i i wouldn't swear to the
physician's possibility there's a time
scale such that that's true that's
called
the minus 25 seconds um if i decide to
do it on ten to the minus
six seconds it's fine the the relevant
coherence
times for radioactive decay about
shorter than that so i can definitely
regard
the the cat state as a superposition of
hundreds of millions of dead cat
branches differing by ten to the minus
six seconds
can i get it down to ten to the minus
twelve seconds yeah probably can i get
ten for those 18 seconds i'm not sure
um and there's no exactly sharp line
where that
um that stops working there'll come a
point
when interference becomes such that the
description in terms of branches
becomes unuseful um there's
that's the point to which the the kind
of there won't be an autonomous high
level dynamics that description that's
the point to which
the kind of real pattern stuff you're a
trip that dad daddy talks about that you
talked about earlier that
that sort of my general license to say
i've got higher level goings on that
license is revoked at the point in which
you get to that that finer grain
but on a coarser grain than that
everything's fine
and there'll be intermediate points
where you can kind of get away with it
but it's a bit fuzzier than you might
like
and sort of depending on your tolerance
for error and the degree of precision in
which you care
you're going to reach different
conclusions as to exactly how finally
you want to break things up
um but the basic claim that there's a
vast number of different cats
is robust against those various ways of
precisifying it
and there's a a lesson or a philosophy
uh implicit here maybe you made it
explicit
um but look these branches are just kind
of approximations they're useful ways of
talking about things and you can't
demand too much precision of them just
like you can't
demand too much precision of treating
the gas in a box as a fluid rather than
a bunch of atoms
that's exactly right i mean this is the
this is the again
this general lesson about emergence
being brought into quantum mechanics
um it's just systematically true that
emerged accounts have fuzz
and slightly blurry boundaries and no
really sharp exact rules as to
um where you divide them out that's
nothing to do with quantum mechanics
that's just generally how the world is
structured
i mean there's a kind of um there's a
kind of temptation to talk about quantum
mechanics and talking about many worlds
in particular
it's less now perhaps there was but it's
still around to say that
there's two options either something
needs to be exactly and precisely
defined
in my microscopic physics or it needs to
be an illusion
but hardly anything in the world fits
those categories you know you and i uh
are not exactly in precise defined there
is no sean david interaction term in the
lagrange of the standard model yeah
um and yet we're not illusory or at
least if we are then the word illusion
becomes loses its value here um
everything higher level has this
fuzziness to it um
and again the the many worlds branches
just have that fuzziness in the same
kind of way um but
the thing the things that are that are
still true no matter how much you
um how much you sort of tweak the setup
those are the robust things so it's
robustly true
that schrodinger's cat um splits into a
vast number of branches
it is not vastly true that the exact
number of those branches is 10 to the
power of 25 or 10 to the power of 18 is
it's robustly true that there are at
least hundreds of millions of them
it's robustly true that there are 10 to
the power of 100 of them
um but there's no there's no robustness
in the middle now
i should confess i mean various of my of
my sort of more purist metaphysically
inclined um
uh colleagues are tearing the hair at
this point because the metaphysics here
is chaos
um but i think i i think our metaphysics
has to be
responsive to our science so to some
extent insofar as we
need to change the way our metaphysics
work to make sense of that kind of way
of talking
that that has to be changed in that way
to do justice to science
and you you seemed to have an implicit
answer to this question in something you
said earlier but there's the question of
when the branching happens
how quickly does it spread should we
think of the branching as
being simultaneous in some arbitrarily
chosen reference frame throughout the
universe
uh like when alice and bob are far apart
with their entangled spins and they're
going to measure them when
ellis measures hers does bob split
instantly or is there some speed of
light delay there
or is that a human construction and we
can choose it either way
yeah i mean it's kind of somewhere in
between and it it's it sort of trades on
an ambiguity about what we mean by
branches here that doesn't matter
in small systems but matters when you've
got the alibaba situation
so here's something that doesn't depend
on how you set it up the
the quantum state of the region of
space-time containing alice
will not change until
uh until light has had a chance to cross
the gap from the region of space time
describing bob
and that's that's the fundamental lower
or more fundamental lower level
description before we start talking
about branches
um i mean there's a bit of branching
even talk about the classical spacetime
or alice and rob but at the level we're
thinking about
we're not we're not thinking branching
here um if you described in branching
terms
the way i prefer to talk would be to say
that i want to think of my branch my
piece of emergency structure is
something
that's expanding on the forward like
cone so alice branches
her future the the the branching spreads
out from alice
at the speed of the fastest interaction
that's doing the
the branching in practice that's going
to always going to be light for big
systems
and bob also has branching happening
and eventually those like kens ken's
crossover and
the the alice like so i'm using my hands
here it's podcast
the alice lycone uh crosses bob the bob
lycone crosses alice um and then alice
and bob split again so alison bob
experienced two sequential splitting
events one when they do their own
measurement and
one where they come into the causal
future of the other measurement
but sometimes it's convenient to talk
more globally if you want to write down
a quantum state and say
we'll do we'll break this state into uh
alice bob both gets spin up plus alice
bob both gets spinned down plus alice
gets spin up bob gets spinned down plus
bob gets
spin up alice gets spinned down um
then we'll want to use a global notion
of branching
um but at that point we're no longer
picking out
a sort of robust higher level feature
anymore with that we've added a piece of
pure convention
and the piece of convention is picked up
by exactly what you were saying earlier
that we've chosen an arbitrary reference
frame
so so we could we could talk that way
now if you want to but nothing
nothing physical is happening
instantaneously even at the emergent
higher level sense
um there is something happening at the
immersion higher level sense but only on
the forward like end of the measurement
okay at least this is the way i think
about it yeah no i think it's a
perfectly i think
it is interesting because it is a kind
of a pressure point of
emergence and subjectivity and
objectivity and all these things so it
you know again
for the youngsters in the audience
there's work to be done in uh thinking
about these things it's not all
yes uh figured out yet and and we
haven't
you know to to bring it all back and
and close the circle um we started this
by saying
that the quantum measurement process is
a manifestly
time irreversible process so
uh how do you explain that mr everett
right well it's i don't necessarily know
the answer
i mean this is like i'll give you a
classic philosophy
to a bigger unsolved problem okay um so
claim this branching is a special case
of thermodynamic irreversibility
um that goes back partly to what i was
saying earlier about
the self-same equation it's happening in
different contexts but we we can break
it down more physically
um the here's the kind of argument you
might give as to
as to why um schrodinger's cat causes
everything to branch out from it i mean
you know a random photon is coming in
towards schrodinger's cat if the
it's if it's coming in from outer space
let's say the if the cat is
alive the photo then the cat's standing
up the photon bounces off the cat
if the cat's dead the photon passes
harmlessly past the cat and bounces off
something different
and so now the quantum state before the
photon arrived was
this this is the very first photon is
cat alive plus cat dead photon coming in
the quantum state afterwards is
catalyzed photon bounced off cat
plus cat dead photon miscat and this is
an entangled state
it's a joint state of both of them the
photon is now recording the quantum
state of the cat and then the idea is
you know millions more photons come in
and to a higher and higher degree um
the cat just thoroughly entangled all
these photons okay but suppose we ran
that process backwards
the backwards description of what's
going on would be something like
initially the photon is entangled
quantum mechanically tangled up with the
cat
and so the total quantum state is
something like uh
photon coming on a one trajectory dead
cat plus photon coming on a different
trajectory
live cat and if you evolve that through
the photon coming in on the live cat
trajectory bounces off the live cat
the photo coming on the dead cat
trajectory keeps going
and now i've got a single photon coming
out
no longer entangled with a cat and if
every single photon was coming in in
quantum states like that
then at the end of all that process the
cat would be in it would the cat would
have started in this ridiculously
entangled stage at the end of the
process
the cat would have been completely pure
so why do we think
one of those happens rather than the
other happens well in some sense we
think that that
that incredibly delicately entangled
state of cat on the million photons
is just a ridiculously implausible
ridiculously unlikely
way for the system to have started off
whereas the state with just all the
photos coming in any which way
that was a perfectly natural reasonable
state um
for the system to have started in
but as i've kind of shown that's an
explicitly time
directed assumption the state that i've
said is is completely outrageous
it's just the state it's just the
reverse of the state the system will in
fact get into in the future
the state i said was perfectly normal
was one that i would have got into
if i ran the ridiculously outrageous
state backwards and all of this is
exactly analogous
to the likelihood of the atoms in a
glass of water
being ready to make an ice cube form
spontaneous
absolutely i'd say it's not even an
analogous it's the same thing
it's just being applied to a different
different problem i mean there's some
slight quantum
subtleties but basically it's the same
thing so the very same things that drive
irreversibility in the ice cube drive
the fact that systems branch rather than
re-emerging i mean again back to the
thing you said right at the beginning is
do i distinguish hours different hours
of time this is one of the reasons i
don't really
if you start talking about the quantum
era of time and the statistical
mechanical area of time you kid yourself
into thinking these are different things
well do not have readings they might be
different things right that's fair
that's fair although it also shows why
everett is better
well yeah it shows why there are
awkwardnesses in not being everetted let
me put it that way
because these these things about the way
systems naturally evolve and decay here
are happening anyway
uh it's kind of weird if separately from
that you've got an entirely different
mechanism
that really imposes the direction i i
mean
uh if you if you if you have some
different explanation of the
of the arrow here you have to ask how
does that mesh with the dika here and
story because
it's gonna hurt him anyway he's
empirically tested i mean not not for
cats but for mesoscopic systems
so just to restate that the thing about
everett whether it's
the fact that there is branching or or
it fits into this bigger statistical
mechanical picture is that
all the processes you need to make
everett work
will also happen in everyone else's
version of quantum mechanics or
statistical mechanics or whatever
but then they're saying and i have extra
processes also because it makes me feel
better somehow
about uh the explanation yeah i mean
yeah
i could make the case for defense
against that but yeah
we're among friends here but okay so and
i'll get back to a difficult question
then um
how do you think about the past
hypothesis in these quantum mechanical
terms is it just one past hypothesis for
the early universe
and its wave function or do we have to
be more subtle about different
senses in which the early universe had
low entropy
well this goes back to why i'd rather i
would rather not place the
past hypothesis as a statement about low
entropy yeah i would rather
put a statement about not having lots of
delicate correlations
i think the past hypothesis is a kind of
cosmic version
of the hypothesis that all the incoming
photons were not complicatedly entangled
i think if our past hypothesis that the
initial quantum state
was a relatively simple state without a
bunch of complicated entanglements
that's probably mostly what we need good
so actually that's that's in fact that's
perfect because
uh we can wrap up the conversation by
going back to the weeds that we were in
a little bit ago that i said
let's let's defer that i think we can do
it now because let me
try to say if i understand what you're
saying in slightly different words then
you can tell me whether i've gotten it
completely
wrong or not there's a version of the
past hypothesis that just says the early
universe had low entropy
oh and by the way it was in a low
entropy state that within its macro
state
uh was pretty generic right it wasn't
not it it wasn't just low entropy it was
low entropy without any secret
conspiracies that was going to make it
even lower entropy right that's that's
one version of past hypothesis
and there's another version that says
look uh we look and we see the
cosmic microwave background in our
telescopes
it's true that if the question you asked
was
of all the ways you could have seen that
what do most of them look like and what
of all the ways the early universe could
have been
to give us this image in our telescopes
what do most of them look like and most
of them look
wildly inhomogeneous with crazy
fluctuations and you know gravitational
differences from here to there and but
there were
were there were there was structure in
the specific
microstate uh that that canceled all
that out so that we see
smooth radiation or telescopes and yeah
and your point if i understand it is
sure if the question you're asking is
just what do most
such early universe states look like
conditioned on what we see
that's the answer you get but if you add
to that a requirement
that what do most early universe states
that didn't have
crazy correlations in them and
conspiracies look like
uh that would give us our state today
then you automatically
can derive the fact that oh it had to be
pretty low entropy in our course grain
sense
was i close that yeah that sounds right
yeah if it
put it this way if the if the early
universe was in a non-crazy
microscopic state then something like
the second law holds and the and
and the macroscopic dynamics for that
universe have entropy going up
yeah and once you've got the macroscopic
dynamics have energy going up
then obviously the entropy of the
earlier universe has to be learned to be
the present universe
good yeah so i i i think that i have not
really sat and chewed on that uh
different formulation
much myself but i'm not objecting to i'm
not i'm not philosophically opposed to
it i think it makes perfect sense and in
fact
uh it leads to i already said this is
the final thing but we have another
final thing now
um it leads into this
the questions that arise in the other
direction of time we've been talking
about the past but we also have the
future
um there are some of my best friends who
worry about the fact that in the future
uh we have a positive cosmological
constant that is making the universe
accelerate
um it will everything will eventually
empty out and we're in what looks like
equilibrium in some sense just empty
space
just sitter space is the technical term
um but the sitter space
has a non-zero temperature according to
stephen hawking and gary gibbons in the
1970s
so there could be random fluctuations
and if you wait a very very long time
you will get fluctuations into
uh boltzmann brains or even entire
boltzmann galaxies or universes
and so forth so are we worried about
getting back
to the recurrence objection that zermelo
gave to boltzmann years ago where uh you
can if you
if you if you say the universe started
14 billion years ago
but lasts infinity years to the future
who cares about the first 14 million
years
most of the occurrences of people like
us will be random fluctuations in the
future is that something that you
personally lose sleep over
oh sleep overstates it but it i think
it's a serious concern
um i think it's a little
a little subtle whether it's true partly
for reasons about what fluctuation
really means in
in an air freshener universe that you've
talked about partly because
ultimately this is probably a physics
that is tentative enough that we should
be
um too much sleep but yeah i mean not
withstanding all of that
um there is something
concerning about it i think if the unit
if the universe is such that it predicts
that
um you know
it's full of beings who have
not even fake histories but entirely
true histories that come from
fluctuations of their own galaxy into
existence or something
um there is i think there's some reason
to be worried that the theory is
self undermining i mean look in a
certain sense it's
there's a bunch of problems i think that
come up in physics where um
we they we we we use we use infinity
pretty casually in physics
and mostly we use infinity as a
convenient approximation for large
finite things
i mean particle physicists talk about uh
collisions between particles and
then we see what happens at infinity and
some philosophers you know better worry
about exactly how you formulate those
infinities but
as my colleague porter williams says the
um the main tube in the lhc
is like about three meters wide and
whatever at infinity is it's much less
than three meters
so case like that all we really mean is
something like much bigger than the
scales we're interested
it's easier to approximate things by
infinity than by some large final number
every now and then a real infinity turns
up um
and when our theory has a real infinity
in this case the literally infinite
future of the decision universe
then then i sort of think at some level
i'm not certain we know how to theorize
about things of that kind
uh and that's not to say therefore we
should be relaxed about
the boltzmann raids that you talk about
it's more the opposite to say this is a
reminder to us that
in positing something that's really
infinite whether it's influence into the
timeline future or
evidence of space it's it's not that
positive illegitimate but that positives
is a very substantial deep thing that
goes beyond our
mathematical use of infinities other
places and we're right to
kind of pause and worry about it yeah i
think that's actually very much in line
with my own view on these things like
it's not a showstopper for anything it's
a reminder
there are things we don't understand and
we shouldn't be too glib about them
um some of my colleagues in cosmology
think that it's
it's a reminder that uh you've lost your
mind that you've worried about these
things
so so for the truly very final answer
um are you mostly encouraged or mostly
discouraged by the relationship between
philosophy and physics these days do you
think that there's been more overlap
that's been constructive
or are do you spend more of your mental
energy sort of
frustrated that it's not even better
i'm mostly positive about it i mean i
suggest that question reflects more
people's natural disposition than
their objective judgment to the field um
my feeling is the philosophy of physics
has upped its game and
has or bits of it at least have
increasingly
engaged with questions in physics that
that genuinely bother physicists
and i think conversely um
physicists it's not true that physicists
are not bothered about conceptual
problems
they're they're they're not bothered
about conceptual problems that are seen
as sterile
and i think the quantum measurement
problem has traditionally often seemed
sterile to physicists it doesn't seem to
lead to
something but but the i mean without
having time to talk about what this is
i imagine your readers your listeners
come across i mean the the
the black hole information lost paradox
has had the
the the finest minds in theoretical
physics tearing their hair out over it
for the better part of 50 years
yeah and it's a conceptual problem it's
not a calculational issue so
it's not these things don't matter um
and i think if you're
if you can if you can come to the table
in that conversation
with somebody contribute then i think
you can
relatively easily get across the
prejudice
that can occur i mean i think you do run
into genuine prejudices
i think it helps to say the word
conceptual rather than philosophical
i think it helps to have a physics phd
or because you could say i have a
physics phd
because of any concrete knowledge you
got from it um
but but i i think i think it could be
done i think there are good
conversations to have and and a lot of
people are willing to talk
and i think um i mean because i've
mostly put that in terms of like what
are the issues of engaging physicists
i think it is true that philosophy of
physics
has some bad habits of its own here that
it can help get everything i think
philosophy of physics has this slightly
awkward situation where
mainstream physicists are not naturally
inclined to talk to them
but people in much more niche areas of
physics who are struggling themselves to
get physicists to talk to them are much
more willing to talk to philosophers
and say philosophy of physics to a
degree that concerns me sometimes can
often be a philosophy of dissident
physics
or minority physics which isn't to diss
any of that i mean we don't do science
by majority vote
but um it does often mean that the
the center of gravity and energy in
philosophy physics
often struggles to be on the conceptual
questions that physicists really care
about um
so so yeah i mean i mean that's kind of
that's a kind of cautious optimism
about it i think i think there's still
problems i think there are institutional
structural problems
and and i also think bluntly many people
doing philosophy of physics or who wants
to philosophy
physics aren't necessarily always doing
their homework to actually get on top of
things
to the degree that they don't make
relatively elementary technical errors
that um that will be seen correctly as
invalidating what they're doing by
physicists they're engaging
with so ultimately doing
interdisciplinary work is hard you have
to collaborate you have to talk to other
people
you have to put the time in um and
there's always a prejudice on both sides
against it that you have to deal with
but
yeah i'm i'm kind of optimistic i think
um
the best days are ahead of it for that
point of view you did a good job of
being optimistic but then being very
cautiously
optimistic but we will take that uh for
what we're looking for here so david
wallace thanks very much for being on
the windscape podcast
thanks for having me
[Music]
so
[Music]
you